[Music]
[Music]
you all right back
no way
it appears that the dimensions are
collapsing on one another
if we cannot get to get
to right the ship i mean we can't be
that far
[Music]
ask nicely slow down please
that's not listening
the dimensions are weakening
[Music]
how considerably is it
[Music]
well it is certainly not good right
get off me ship
ratchet we are too late
ratchet
[Music]
who
[Music]
hi i'm marcus smith creative director at
insomniac games
the entire studio is so excited to be
able to share with you a first ever look
at ratchet and clank rift apart
a brand new full-length
inter-dimensional adventure built from
the ground up for the playstation 5.
we're doing things we've never been able
to do before like use dimensional rifts
to be able to leap from planet to planet
nearly instantly or
put ray trace reflections on clank all
of our alien worlds are filled with
density and life
previously unseen plus ratchet's all-new
arsenal
is more exciting than ever thanks to the
dual sense controller's enhanced
feedback
ratchet and clank are near and dear to
our hearts at insomniac and we can't
wait to share more with you in the
future
but for now here's another look
did you see that
from above
[Applause]
or at least a very large octopus
[Applause]
that's what i'm afraid
oh
oh
that's all of them
[Music]
you